welcome to this video playing bingo
Bongo bingo bongo from from from from I
think it's from Germany right i'm not
mistaken but he's got no flag in there
ok the decline smith [ __ ] somehow i get
this all the time why ok this time wyd
allow it this the strait of the light
squared Bishop which is of course
something that I welcome this emphasizes
the control over the dark squares
hmm I'm on my way getting a night to
deform 96-94 that that's what I want one
of the things that black can do I mean
not the only plan but not a bad plan can
also I mean it would be nice if I get
dark squared Bishop straight it is there
some some way to do that Bishop before
or something I don't know just play a
little waiting move and I was what I
wanted I wanted to cover e7 so Queen a
five it's not neglecting the e74 Queen a
59 a four hour between a 5-2 win to do
something on the queenside not so clear
what his next move was yeah this one
maybe I was just about to say that this
is possible here after a three I have
night be three
ok I was thinking of e 6 anyway i'm not
sure if this is a good idea or not okay
just just do it
okay hmm ditto will look something I
take here I need to do it anyway what
what is smile what did they overlooked I
didn't I don't see it what is the
problem this is just a pawn right I mean
rock d6 I have 94 @ at least them and
this is then just a pawn on white resins
oh well that's only yeah probably i
don't know what you relied upon but I
mean rook these six really root d6 yeah
it's just a pawn can go here try it for
counter play now I can I can also do
this here if we look at this this kind
of position I'm I'm really enjoying this
this fantastic Bishop which will come to
d4 and pressurize f 2 and tier his
Bishop is really bad on b1 it just looks
at its own poor Nia later and first and
foremost it looks at a very sound porn
structure now that's it's very good for
black I think it's okay before of course
was a blunder but if we start right
early real early I think it's a good
idea for white to prepare Knight f3 with
the move h3 so that I cannot exchange my
bishop this Bishop is notoriously and is
one of that not that one this Bishop is
notoriously useless in a structure like
that so it's a
good idea to trade it and now I only
have pieces if you as you can see here
that work on the dark squares like here
dark square dark square dark square it's
it's all focused on dark square
controller and he really has a weak spot
on deform here 95 and I mean here here
95 e6 and yeah he should just go back
and this is not not at all not at all
clear this position Lizzie six members
of course something that that is
debatable here I'm weakening my my pawn
structure I've got a big pawn on d6 but
on the other hand I also yeah got
control over d 5 so that his night is
not such a pest 25 anymore I was
intending Luke ad ATM which is not good
okay because of 95 yeah it's a bit
difficult to cover that so maybe I need
to do this here
it's surprisingly good for black
interesting
some 93 I need to do this yeah i'm not
sure okay well this is not that
difficult to see but i'm not sure what I
would have done that here I really just
take it yeah maybe he thought something
like we should be too wet or I can just
take the night yeah I don't know okay
thanks for watching